[Applaudissements]
en 1958 général de Gaulle ne pensait pas
revenir au pouvoir peut-être même qu'il
ne le souhaitait pas
[Applaudissements]
je suis complètement convaincu qu'il
avait la certitude que l'Algérie serait
indépendante depuis très longtemps avant
une carrière de dictateur
[Applaudissements]
je crois que la force du gaullisme en 58
c'est que les gaullistes ont une option
ils ont une solution Charles de Gaulle
c'est un stratège avec un sens très aigu
de la combinatoire et du moment où il
faut engager la manœuvre
le 10 septembre 1958 le général de
Gaulle réunit ses partisans place de la
République tout un symbole
le général est de retour la France va
décider une fois de plus de confier son
destin à un homme providentiel
cette histoire du retour du général a
débuté au printemps près de quatre mois
auparavant pour le printemps du général
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1958 c'est l'histoire du moi où la
France et le général de Gaulle vont se
retrouver des retrouvailles forcés avec
une odeur de poudre deux hommes trois
lieux Alger d'abord c'est là où en dépit
des victoires militaires la France
heurte au FLN qui veut l'indépendance
pour l'Algérie
[Musique]
à Collombey le général de Gaulle depuis
son retrait de la vie politique en 1946
attend ce moment
et ce moment c'est à Paris qu'il se joue
René Coty depuis l'Élysée constate la
vacance du pouvoir
l'incapacité des députés a constitué un
gouvernement la Quatrième République est
à l'agonie le mois de mai 58 sera son
coup de grâce
[Musique]
14 avril 1958 le gouvernement Félix
Gaillard est renversé l'air est instable
la France toujours en Lisée dans le
bourbier algérien mais à Colombet le
général ne songe pas au pouvoir il
affiche toujours pour la quatrième
République un souverain mépris qui le
pousse à rester loin de toute agitation
politique
c'est vrai que il analyse la vie
politique de la Quatrième République et
avec
tous les poisons et les délices des
partis politiques qu'ils réprouvent que
il voit la situation en Algérie qui
tourne plutôt mal et qui se sent aussi
un devoir vis-à-vis de la France de
revenir aux affaires si nécessaire
un jour deux jours trois jours une
semaine deux semaines le temps passe et
la France est toujours sans gouvernement
à Paris on est incapable de faire face à
la pression venue d'Alger la situation
est sans issue c'est le moment idéal
pour forcer le destin la nature a
horreur du vide dit-on l'égoliste long
compris on fait appel pour cela un mari
Madeleine Fourcade elle a été udée seule
femme à diriger un réseau de Résistance
dès 1940 sa proximité avec l'extrême
droite et le monde militaire en fait une
pièce maîtresse
Marie-Madeleine Fourcade elle incarne en
1958 à la fois un héritage résistant
incontestable une dimension non moins
importante liée à toute la question du
renseignement des réseaux et d'un
travail souterrain et puis bien entendu
la possibilité qui lui est offerte à
travers son nom et ce qu'elle symbolise
de faire revivre un peu comme les marins
de l'île de Sein la légende de 1940 ce
mythe qui s'est construit et qui est
pour ses acteurs une véritable épopée
[Musique]
qui conservèrent l'espoir souvenons-nous
ils furent les premiers à bord de ce
petit bâtiment la première unité des
Forces navales libres ces hommes qui
vivaient sur la mer s'embarquèrent tous
pour un long voyage un très long voyage
dont beaucoup ne sont pas revenus
il faut se souvenir
1940 ils étaient 128 à avoir quitté
l'île de Saint tous pécheurs et tous
venus retrouver le général de Gaulle à
Londres au lendemain de l'appel du 18
juin
qui souhaitaient le retour du général de
Gaulle on réactivé tous leurs réseaux de
la France libre et les pêcheurs de l'île
de Sein sont un élément symbolique
important de ces réseaux gaullistes et
de cette attachement à la défense de la
France
les pêcheurs de l'île de Sein vont sous
l'autorité de Marie-Madeleine Fourcade
venir déposer des lettres au président
Coty pour réclamer le retour aux
affaires du général dans la foulée cent
mille Français tous sympathisants
gaullistes vont aussi écrire au
président de la République
le compagnonnage des hommes de la France
Libre est une réalité il permet d'être
efficace lorsque le mois de mai débute
tout a été mis en place pour pouvoir
conquérir le pouvoir tout commence le 5
mai 1958
[Musique]
allez lisez le général ganval appelle
l'aide de camp du général de Gaulle il
lui demande un rendez-vous
[Musique]
dans la nuit parisienne les proches du
général Olivier Guichard Roger frais se
retrouve chez Jacques Foucart
l'heure est au complot
[Musique]
la nuit aura été courte et au petit
matin pour les gaullistes le paysage
politique n'est plus tout à fait le même
[Musique]
à Collombey conséquences de la réunion
de la nuit le général attend la visite
d'Olivier Guichard et de Michel Debré il
s'agit de répondre à la lettre du
président de la République
en prenant la route ces gaullistes
historiques se disent que 7 fois ce sera
peut-être la bonne car pour eux c'est
une évidence la lettre du président Coty
remet en scène le général
bon petit n'a pas de gouvernement
puisque tous les présidents du Conseil
pressenti refusent il faut trouver une
solution d'où le message qu'il transmet
à de Gaulle parce que là il se dit qu'il
faut passer à l'acte il faut quand même
sonder le général de Gaulle pour essayer
de sentir si le général de Gaulle est
disponible pour revenir aux affaires ou
pas je pense que le président Coty
cherche en fait deux choses d'abord
sont des très probablement quelles sont
les intentions du général lui-même
sachant que les gaullistes s'agitent
énormément tant métropole qu'en Algérie
ou du moins un certain nombre d'entre
eux commencent à eux aussi avoir en
Algérie dans quelle mesure il pourrait
profiter éventuellement de la situation
et puis deuxième élément il se dit que
peut-être
le général de Gaulle pourrait être un
recours dans la mesure où il ne
parviendrait pas à sortir de la crise
par les moyens habituels
à Collombey le général fait taper sa
réponse elle est sans équivaut il fait
preuve d'une détermination sans faille
quant à sa critique des institutions de
la Quatrième République et ce faisant il
cache bien son jeu
le général fait répondre au président
Coty
d'une façon qui ne convient pas
véritablement au président de la
République parce que de Gaulle demande
une lettre écrite du président de la
République
demande que les parties politiques
soient d'accord tout en disant que si le
Parti communiste n'est pas favorable bon
il n'a pas beaucoup d'importance et
demande aussi à ne pas être présent au
moment de du vote de l'investiture à la
Chambre des députés et pour René Coty
c'est une réponse inquiétante parce que
ça signifie que le général de Gaulle ne
veut pas jouer le jeu des institutions
il pose ses conditions et il ne veut pas
respecter les règles de la Quatrième
République
René Coty n'est pas à Orléans pour fêter
Jeanne la Pucelle il devait s'y rendre
il a dû rester à l'Élysée il a pris
connaissance des exigences posées par le
général
des conditions impossibles dans la
quatrième République l'hypothèse du
général s'éloigne donc sans autre
solution à 22h30 le président de la
République appelle pierre flimlin pour
lui demander de devenir président du
conseil il est pourtant
omi par l'armée en Algérie qui le
soupçonne de vouloir aller vers
l'indépendance
dans la nuit un drame survient un drame
qui va accélérer le cours des choses
le FLN avait enlevé en janvier dans le
djebel algérien 4 jeunes appelés du
contingent avant de les cacher en
Tunisie ce 9 mai les dirigeants du FLN
revendiquent l'exécution de trois des
otages la nouvelle fait l'effet d'une
bombe on bascule dans la radicalisation
à Paris la classe politique est jugée
incapable de protéger les Français
Alger ont bascule de la colère à la
haine contre les Algériens tout se met
progressivement en place pour aller au
drame
cet enlèvement renforce la défiance dans
la mesure où à ce moment-là encore les
l'opinions publiques considèrent que
cette guerre d'Algérie est légitime
simplement elle veut en voir le résultat
et elle veut en voir également la fin ça
c'est un élément très important une
victoire militaire au bout le maintien
de l'Algérie française ce sont au fond
les objectifs de l'opinion publique mais
cet incident est aussi un moyen par
lequel les tenants de l'Algérie
française vont mobiliser un certain
nombre de troupes par des manifestations
de troupes militantes j'entends par des
manifestations
Alger les partisans de l'Algérie
française veulent se servir de ce drame
pour peser sur Paris Pierre Plumelin
n'inspire pas confiance et surtout son
gouvernement l'armée se dit qu'elle
détient là une occasion de se faire
entendre
de retour d'Algérie le général Élie chef
d'état-major écrit au général de Gaulle
le général Eli qui est chef d'état-major
des armées donc vraiment un poste
imminent et très inquiet de la situation
en Algérie il est allé le 7 mai il est
rentré très inquiet de en voyant
l'atmosphère de l'armée la combativité
des capitaines des colonels en même
temps il est très Gauliste et il pense
aussi que le général de Gaulle et le
seul à pouvoir régler la situation je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait véritablement de
militaires ouvertement gaulliste avec
cette idée au fond comme rejoindre de
l'aube ou appeler de Gaulle ail dans le
sens d'un vœu politique qui serait
véritablement l'odeur un certain nombre
d’ailleurs de militaires c'était très
bien accommodé des gouvernements
socialistes de Guy Mollet notamment
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un élément qui
est très important c'est que
l'armée l'état-major
a pu profiter de la faiblesse de la
Quatrième République simplement la
situation effectivement en 1958 et
beaucoup plus compliqué ce profil avec
Pierre fimelin le démocrate chrétien la
possibilité entre voit-il dans des
engagement possible et à ce moment-là le
choix du général de Gaulle apparaît
comme un choix de raison
à Collombey le général a pris
connaissance de la lettre du général
Elie il consulte s'il n'entend pas
revenir par la force il sait qu'il peut
tirer parti de la situation
[Musique]
qu'il a reçu énormément de gens mais il
se garde bien de montrer quoi que ce
soit de ce qu'il pensait de la situation
il laissait faire il se garde bien de
susciter des réactions des uns et des
autres temps en temps il provoquait ses
interlocuteurs pour savoir
éventuellement ce qu'il pensait dans tel
ou tel sens en reposant des questions
qui allaient à rebours de ce qu'on
pouvait penser mais il ne suscitait
absolument rien et surtout une provoque
rien il laissait venir en 1958 ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que de Gaulle
incarnent une figure d'homme politique
de premier plan c'est un vrai politique
la dimension militaire du personnage ne
joue pas un rôle central sauf évidemment
vis-à-vis de des autres militaires et de
l'image qui est évidemment celle du
général dans l'opinion publique avec
tous l'héritage de la France libre de
1944 etc etc et je dirais que
effectivement le général de Gaulle est
un homme politique en uniforme beaucoup
plus qu'un militaire qui fait de la
politique Charles de Gaulle c'est un
stratège avec un sens très aigu de la
combinatoire et du moment où il faut
engager la manœuvre tant qu'il ne
sentait pas que les choses étaient mûres
se gardait bien de sortir trop tôt de la
tranchée et de se faire tirer dessus
à Colombey chez les gaullistes on
auscule on regarde la situation
Alger il n'y a plus de temps à perdre et
surtout il faut plus que jamais défier
le pouvoir parisien
l'armée regroupée autour du général
salon décide de prendre part à la
manifestation prévue le lendemain en
hommage aux trois militaires français
tués
c'est aussi le jour de l'investiture du
nouveau président du conseil mais
surtout il est décidé d'un coup d'éclat
qui doit renverser le cours de
l'histoire
[Musique]
salon c'est un général républicain
l'égalises mais en même temps marqué par
la perte de l'Indochine il a fait
l'Indochine et c'est quelque chose qu'il
a vraiment marqué et comme il est tout à
fait représentatif de l'armée française
qui considère que
l'Algérie française est vraiment le
dernier bastion qu'il faut garder et
qu'on ne peut pas l'armer ne peut pas se
permettre de perdre l'Algérie française
mais il est légalistes républicain
[Musique]
le 13 mai 1958 constitue une date de
notre histoire pour certains cela
restera un coup d'état c'est en tout cas
un coup de force qui acte le décès futur
de la Quatrième République la journée se
passe en 4 actes
[Musique]
Alger une manifestation est prévue en
hommage aux trois soldats tués par le
FLN
[Musique]
tout à l'heure nous nous retrouverons
tous nos plateaux des Glières par
milliers pour manifester contre toute
politique d'Abondance à midi des
voitures équipées de haut-parleur invite
les Algérois manifester
un quart d'heure à 14h grève générale
les magasins sont fermés les rideaux
tirés
le magasin est enfermé à 100%
c'est le général salon qui a choisi la
date du 13 mai parce que justement
c'était le jour de l'investiture de fine
donc il y a une espèce de conjonction
entre les deux crises la crise politique
à Paris qu'on espère bientôt dénouer et
la crise militaire et algérienne à Alger
donc sur le plateau des Glières
rendez-vous au pied du monument aux
morts ou à peu près 100 000 personnes
sont présentes
[Musique]
on a décidé la grève générale
l'après-midi du 13 mai pour que les gens
puissent venir à la manifestation
la rue des bornes Alger et descendu dans
la rue pour dire son attachement à la
France ici loin de la métropole
l'arrivée de Pierre pumelin inquiète les
Pieds-Noirs ont peur d'être oublié
plateau des Glières à Alger la foule se
sent forte un homme s'impose il s'agit
de Pierre Lagaillarde en tenue de
parachutiste il interpelle les
manifestants depuis le monument aux
morts on passe de la colère à la révolte
c'est l'acte 2
en réalité c'est le porte-parole d'une
opinion à la fois qu'il galvanise mais
en même temps qu'il incarne à travers
effectivement le sentiment qu'a cette
population française d'Algérie non pas
encore d'être abandonnés mais de l'être
peut-être possiblement par un pouvoir
parisien métropolitain trop éloigné
d'elle
il en appelle à la nécessité pour cette
population européenne d'Algérie de
s'organiser et l'idée c'est
véritablement de montrer de faire monter
la pression vis-à-vis de Paris c'est un
jeu de c'est un jeu de pression de
montrer que aucune décision ne pourrait
être prise à Paris qui irait à
l'encontre des intérêts et de l'avenir
de l'Algérie française
pierre Lagaillarde a mis le feu c'est le
début de l'insurrection avec l'assaut du
gouvernement général par des
manifestants décidés à en découdre c'est
l'acte 3
[Musique]
prendre d'assaut le GG le gouvernement
général c'est le rêve et ce qui
s'éveille par le général salon
[Musique]
Alger défi Paris avec une leçon claire
timelin n'est pas encore investi à Paris
que déjà le pouvoir vacillage
voilà la leçon adressée au plus haut
sommet de l'État
[Musique]
est envahi et le balcon tient lieu de
vitrine d'une armée victorieuse décidait
à prendre les choses en Inde c'est
l'acte 4
le général salant vient au balcon et
s'adresse à la foule il crie
[Musique]
lesondelles
lui intime l'ordre de crier vive de
Gaulle
il revient en balcon écrit vive de
[Musique]
au même moment à Paris le président
filmlin est investi enfin puis me
l'investit à Paris De Gaulle par la
foule à Alger désormais c'est un
face-à-face qui s'installe pour ceux qui
sera en réalité les derniers jours de la
Quatrième République
pierre fimlin et membre du MRT donc
évidemment c'est un parti central du de
l'arc politique mais pour l'armée
flimlin est une figure comme on dit à
l'époque de libérale de libéral et on
s'inquiète quand ça ces intentions
concernant l'Algérie française
mais surtout à Alger le général massue
annonce la création d'un Comité de salut
public
on retrouve sans surprise les noms de
léodelbeke et de Pierre la Gaillarde
Paris doit répliquer
massue prononce son discours il est à
peu près 20h quelque chose comme ça
fleemelin et est investi plus tard dans
la nuit donc il y a toujours cette
course de vitesse mais en même temps
massue est un gaulliste infidèle un
Français libre fidèle du général
donc il s'agit de pouvoir maintenir
l'armée son autorité entendre la foule
défendre l'Algérie française
organisé une structure donc qui se
Comité de salut public qui pourrait
éventuellement rétablir le calme
à côté du général salon qui a eu les
pleins pouvoirs civils et militaires
accordés par Félix Gaillard et que
quelques heures plus tard
fimlin confirmera massue est un homme
qui est un militaire qui a dans la
population européenne d'Algérie un écho
absolument incontestable pour les
Européens d'Algérie c'est aussi l'homme
qui a rétabli l'ordre public
Alger pendant la guide bataille d'Alger
et en plus derrière massue il y a toute
la figure des parents etc il y a dans
cette population européenne d'Algérie un
élément qui faut absolument avoir à
l'esprit c'est leur culte du leur culte
de l'uniforme le culte du drapeau et
massue en est une incarnation
le 14 au petit jour le président Coty a
dure l'armée de rester dans Le Devoir
sous l'autorité du gouvernement de la
République
le général salant entraîné à son corps
défendant dans cette aventure et
maintenu comme faisant fonction de
gouverneur affublé des pouvoirs civils
par le nouveau gouvernement investi
grâce aux abstentions communistes
les avions à destination d'Alger sont
interdits de vol il est dans le même
temps décidé de couper les
communications téléphoniques avec
l'Afrique du Nord
[Musique]
au petit matin à Paris un homme
missionné par Marcel Dassault remet une
mallette un proche du général de Gaulle
l'industriel français a en effet ouvert
une ligne de crédit pour le général
Pierre de Bénouville est à la manœuvre
Marcel Dassault a effectivement mon les
moyens qu'on lui connaît et de ce point
de vue il est important sans doute pour
le général de Gaulle de s'appuyer
effectivement sur cette figure qui va
mettre sa puissance financière au
service de ses convictions de ces
intérêts grâce à l'argent de Marcel
Dassault Jacques Soustelle ancien
gouverneur en Algérie est proche du
général filant Suisse caché dans un
coffre de DS et prend l'avion à
destination d'Alger de Monsieur
Soustelle qui est clandestinement le
territoire métropolitain pour la Suisse
d'où il avait affrêté un avion spécial
n'était pas faite pour rendre désertes
la place du forum où le général massue
président du comité dit de salut public
l'accompagnait avec le général Salan
Soustons pour les Français d'Alger le
nom résonne favorablement Jacques
Soustons l'homme vient de la gauche et
après son passage en Algérie il devient
l'un des plus ardents défenseurs d'une
Algérie française
il doit faire face aux réserves du
général pour qu'il apparaît comme trop
lié aux Français d'Algérie Retif a tout
changement
est convaincu qu'il faudra mettre fin à
cet Algérie française à un moment qui
conviendra pas forcément dans l'immédiat
et à des conditions qu'il entend décider
et Soustelle est trop Algérie française
pour de Gaulle trop proche des
activistes pour de Gaulle autant de
Gaulle ne veut pas revenir aux affaires
dans les valises de l'armée autant il ne
veut pas revenir par la grâce de Jacques
Soustelle
[Musique]
à Colombé le général de Gaulle fait
taper un communiqué qu'il impose
implicitement comme un recours
la dégradation de l'état entraîne
infailliblement l'éloignement des
peuples associés le trouble de l'armée
au combat la dislocation nationale la
perte de l'indépendance depuis 12 ans la
France aux prises avec des problèmes
trop rudes pour le régime des parties
est engagé dans ce processus désastreux
la guerre le pays dans ses profondeurs
m'a fait confiance pour le conduire tout
entier jusqu'à son salut aujourd'hui
devant les épreuves qui montent de
nouveau vers lui qu'il sache que je me
tiens prêt à assumer les pouvoirs de la
République
pierre Plumelin tente de reprendre la
main il cherche un accord avec le
général salon
le 17 mai mettait en balance en quelque
sorte la démission de fimlin où la
formation d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale mais donc qui intégrerait des
partisans de l'Algérie française mais il
fait confiance à ça puisqu'il lui a
confirmé les pleins pouvoirs civils
militaires flimlin cherche évidemment
des gaz en s'appuyant sur sa langue en
temps normal les choses auraient pu
fonctionner sauf que depuis le 13 et 14
mai la dynamique est lancée la dynamique
d'un retour au pouvoir du général de
Gaulle lancer et le général de Gaulle
lui-même n’entend absolument pas
évidemment faire cesser cette dynamique
au contraire pour que l'accord entre
salon et firmelin uplumarché il lui
fallut il lui fallut que le général de
Gaulle 10 tout simplement après l'appel
qui lui avait été lancé à Alger depuis
le forum écoutez je vous remercie
beaucoup de m'avoir appelé mais ne
comptez pas sur moi je reste en réserve
je reste à Colombet il n'est pas
question pour moi de revenir au pouvoir
à ce moment là l'hypothèque gaulliste
aurait été levée et peut-être que
flimlin aurait pu évidemment essayer de
s'inscrire dans un temps politique plus
long mais de l'instant où le général de
Gaulle a fait absolument l'inverse
l'inverse pardon il est clair que
l'avenir politique de flemmlin est un
avenir politique sur lequel les acteurs
et notamment militaires ne peuvent pas
compter
Alger signe pas tant de cette défiance
pour le président du Conseil les
manifestations se multiplient
[Musique]
depuis le 13 mai Alger accentue la
pression sur Paris manifestation
opération militaire nombreuse et
toujours en arrière-plan la figure du
général qui lui a Collombey a décidé de
jouer la montre
de Gaulle tient à la légalité
républicaine ne veut pas être l'homme
d'un coup d'État ne veut pas revenir
dans les valises de l'armée et donc il
décide de parler
le général de Gaulle marche pour une
conférence de presse qui va rester dans
les annales près de son bureau de la rue
de Solférino le général joue son va tout
surtout qu'il reste pour beaucoup un
homme à combattre il y a comme une odeur
de soufre pour une très grande partie du
corps politique français
de Gaulle c'était le séditieux c'était
l'homme dont il fallait se méfier
c'était pour beaucoup le militaire qui
avait
des tendances dictatoriales beaucoup le
disait cette conférence de presse elle a
été terriblement encadrée par la police
tout le palais d'Orsay était quadrillé
par les CRS il ne faut pas oublier aussi
que c'est bon apôts de la République qui
avaient la démocratie plein la bouche
était les mêmes qui dès 1947 avait
interdit générale de Gaulle d'utiliser
les ondes publiques
et que la conférence du palais d'Orsay a
été faite à titre privé avec les
télévisions étrangères les images que
l'on voit sont celles des télévisions
étrangères pas de la télévision
française
[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai jamais attentif aurait
pu liberté publique fondamentale je les
ai rétabli ayez une seconde à tenter
jamais pourquoi voulez-vous qu'à 67 ans
je commence une carrière de dictateur
[Applaudissements]
c'était le séditieux il fallait s'en
méfier et pour de Gaulle le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que les les carottes
n'étaient pas cuites et qu'il fallait
que l'intention lui permettant de
revenir dans des conditions qu'ils
souhaitaient à ce moment-là n'était
absolument pas encore formé
on prend parfaitement bien
l'attitude et l'action du commandement
militaire en Algérie je ne répondrai
qu'à ce qui a très
à la question des institutions
moi contre ici si vous voulez bien
la République
j'ai redressé ses armes c'est loin son
nom quant à l'armée qui est normalement
l'instrument de l'État et bien encore
faut-il qu'il est en état
et je dis le général des joues un à un
tous les pièges il est l'homme qui défie
tout à la fois le président firmelin
mais au-delà les institutions de la
Quatrième République
je n'ai pas besoin d'expliquer mieux
pour quelle raison j'offre une solution
la conférence de presse du 19 mai est un
moment effectivement essentiel de
l'histoire du gaulisme mais c'est aussi
un élément magistral le général de
Gaulle est magistral du début à la fin
c'est un c'est un acteur politique de
premier plan tout y est de 77 ans et la
carrière du dictateur jusqu'à la fin
quand il explique il retourne chez lui
et dans son village et il attend
maintenant je vais rentrer dans mon
village
et je m'y tiendrai à la disposition du
pays ces magistral pourquoi parce que la
conférence du 19 mai on peut la lire
comme un point d'aboutissement un point
d'aboutissement lié à la lettre
effectivement de Coty bien sûr mais
également de l'appel au pouvoir qu'a
lancé la foule d'Alger ce qui se passe
en ce moment en Algérie par rapport à la
métropole
et dans la métropole par rapport à
l'Algérie reconduire
[Musique]
à une crise nationale extrêmement grave
mais aussi ce peut être
le début d'une espèce de résurrection
voilà pourquoi
le moment m'a semblé venu
où il pourrait mettre possible
d'être utile
encore une fois directement à la France
ce qui est intéressant c'est que de
Gaulle dans les premiers mots de sa
conférence de presse parle de
résurrection
donc ce qui montre bien que les choses
vont changer que le cours de l'histoire
de du pays va changer le cours des
événements va va être modifié si une
résurrection c'est que quelque chose de
mort bon c'est une façon de dire que le
gouvernement de flemlin ne tient pas ne
tiendra pas le général de Gaulle est de
ce point de vue là extrêmement conscient
que le 19 mai la situation lui est
favorable mais la situation n'est pas
mûre pas complètement mûre il est
certain que si de Gaulle
est déterminé à assumer
à se voir déléguer
des pouvoirs exceptionnels pour une
tâche exceptionnelle dans un moment
exceptionnel
évidemment ça pourrait pas se faire
suivant les rites et la procédure
tellement habituelle
que tout le monde en est excédé
donc il faudrait adopter une procédure
elle aussi exceptionnelle le général en
temps et attend qu'on l'appelle en
disant mais moi je ne demande rien à
personne mais en même temps c'est aussi
un moyen de se mettre en avant il laisse
de nouveau un vide derrière lui
simplement évidemment le vide qui laisse
en réalité
il l'occupe au moins dans les esprits et
à partir de là la position de pierre
fimelin est une transition de plus en
plus intenable
désormais le face-à-face est imposé de
Gaulle façade féminin avec l'armée pour
intimider et le bourbier algérien comme
tragique des corps
[Musique]
depuis Alger des membres de l'état-major
conçoivent l'opération résurrection
aéroportée elle lâcherait des
parachutistes sur Paris avec l'appui
d'un groupement blindé stationné sur les
pourtours de la capitale
plus tard le général de Gaulle écrira
[Musique]
il était clair qu'on allait directement
à la subversion avec l'arrivée soudaine
à Paris d'une avant-garde aéroportée
l'établissement d'une dictature
militaire fondée sur un état de siège
analogue à celui d'Alger
Paul se pose alors en médiateur entre
les militaires et ceux qui restent
encore du pouvoir civil
mais en fait il profite de la menace des
militaires
l'armée compte sur De Gaulle pour
maintenir l'Algérie française et
restaurer donc l'autorité de la France
du pouvoir en Algérie
de régler les questions militaires et
politiques il y a une pression
très vive de l'armée enfin de ceux qui
préparent cette opération militaire donc
grenade qui est devenu résurrection et
qui est de plus en plus pressante
bonsoir du 19 mai il peut considérer
effectivement donc l'armée va être de
son côté très probablement ça c'est un
question sans doute réglée il se retire
mais le général de Gaulle mais
au fond face à face l'opinion publique
l'armée et impersonnel politique qui
jusqu’alors s'est tenu dans une position
d'attente et qui là va devoir choisir
qui va devoir choisir une option celle
du général de Gaulle qui n'était tout de
même pas celle à laquelle aspirait les
dirigeants politiques de la France de la
Quatrième République quelques jours plus
tôt donc c'est les stockad elle est
prévue pour le personnel politique et là
il va falloir une dizaine de jours
[Musique]
des parents d'Algés débarquent encore
Corse c'est l'opération résurrection en
quelques heures il se rendent maître de
l'île avec la neutralité bienveillante
des CRS et des autorités locales comme à
Alger les militaires installent un
comité de salut public comme à Alger les
gaullistes vont profiter de la situation
à Collombey le général écrit dans son
journal le 24 mai a détachement parti
d'Alger à atterri encore se sent
couperrir grâce à quoi des comités de
salut public ont saisi l'Autorité à
Ajaccio et à Bastia les forces de police
envoyer depuis Marseille sur Lille pour
y rétablir l'ordre ce sont laissés
facilement désarmés que la solution
politique soit retardée et l'on verra
certainement de semblables opérations
exécutées dans la métropole puis dirigé
sur Paris
[Musique]
entre intimidation et opportunisme
politique c'est un formidable coup de
force des gaullistes
[Musique]
à la Boisserie le général a fait venir
le préfet de la Haute-Marne Marcel
dibolt il lui demande de transmettre au
président du conseil pierre pimlin sa
volonté de le voir au plus vite
[Musique]
à Paris Pierre plimelin accepte le
général de Gaulle lui se rend au lieu du
rendez-vous
le rendez-vous est fixé à 10 heures du
soir à Saint-Cloud dans le plus grand
secret entre fimelin et de Gaulle cette
rencontre elle est extraordinaire de par
le lieu de par son horaire
dans une maison à Saint-Cloud de nuit
donc c'est une demande de De Gaulle à
laquelle flimlin se rend ce qui est tout
à fait clair c'est que en s'y rendant
flimlin considère qu'il a déjà perdu et
flimlin demande à de Gaulle de désavouer
l'opération résurrection ce que de
Gaulle ne fait pas comment peut-il
s'opposer en général de Gaulle si vous
voulez s'opposer au retour au pouvoir du
général de Gaulle il n'avait finalement
qu'à ne pas rencontrer le général de
Gaulle en disant que le président du
Conseil c'était lui la position de film
là elle est insupportable
[Musique]
cette rencontre secrète c'est celle qui
oppose un homme qui a déjà perdu et
improbable vainqueur le président du
Conseil sait qu'il va tomber dans sa
chute il emporte la Quatrième République
et son régime des parties le général
sait qu'il va gagner la question qui se
pose à lui et de savoir comment il va
pouvoir imposer ses vues à l'ensemble
des députés
[Musique]
je pense que c'est le constat de décès
de la Quatrième République et je dirais
que pour filmer c'est sans doute aussi
le constat alors c'est une sorte
évidemment pas compte à ce moment-là
mais sans doute le constat de décès de
sa propre carrière politique
[Musique]
pierre pumelin pensez avoir bu le calice
jusqu'à la lie
mais pourtant pour lui le pire est à
venir
[Musique]
j'ai entamé hier le processus régulier
nécessaire à l'établissement d'un
gouvernement républicain capable
d'assurer l'unité et l'indépendance du
pays je compte que ce processus va se
poursuivre et que le pays fera voir par
son calme et sa dignité qu'il souhaite
le voir aboutir
j'attends des forces terrestres navales
et aériennes présentes en Algérie
qu'elle demeure exemplaire sous les
ordres de leur chef
à ses chefs j'exprime ma confiance et
mon intention de prendre incessamment
contact avec eux
il y a un coup de force politique avec
exploitation d'une situation qui tranche
totalement avec les usages de la
troisième comme de la Quatrième
République dans ce communiqué d'abord
c'est le général de Gaulle qui se
présente lui-même
il explique qu'il a entamé le processus
régulier etc bon il annonce au fond la
possibilité de son retour au pouvoir
contre tous les usages puisque c'était
théoriquement le président de la
République qui
appelait pressentait un président du
conseil chargé de former un gouvernement
se communiquer montre tout à la fois
l'extraordinaire habileté politique du
général et le manque total de
considération qui l'éprouve pour Pierre
fimelin jamais lors de la rencontre de
la veille le général n'avait fêté de son
intention de publier un tel communiqué
Finlande était furieux vraiment furieux
blessé
humiliant évidemment pour lui et il
voulait répondre à ce communiqué et le
président Coty l'en a dissuadé parce que
pour Coty il est évident que la carte de
Gaulle et la carte qu'il faut jouer
c'est le film là depuis plus servir
d'atouts si de Gaulle fait cela c'est
pour à mon sens de raison la première
c'est pour montrer que c'est bien lui
qui est le patron qui est le maître de à
la fois il est le maître des horloges
depuis le début
il s'en va il attend il est le maître
des horloges il est également le maître
de la situation mais il sait en même
temps que il a à ce moment-là l'appui
est bien entendu du président de la
République et que l'histoire elle est
écrite
[Musique]
j'ai exposé à monsieur le Président de
la République
la situation au moment où il faut
affronter des tâches de plus en plus
redoutable
en conséquence j'ai présenté ma
démission de Guerlain jette les ponts
en effet à midi René Coty demande à de
Gaulle de recevoir Gaston Monnerville et
André Le Trocquer président des deux
chambres qui composent le Parlement
c'est entrevue a lieu le soir même André
le troquerère socialiste dit tout net à
de Gaulle qui l'entend s'opposer à sa
venue au pouvoir la réaction du général
de Gaulle et limpide et bien si le
Parlement vous suit je n'aurais pas
autre chose à faire que de vous laisser
vous expliquer avec les parachutistes
au même moment la gauche descend dans la
rue pour s'opposer au retour du général
en dépit d'un réel succès plus de 500
000 manifestants la gauche est inaudible
pour Guy Mollet Pierre Mendès France se
sont d'abord les leçons d'un échec
ils ont été élus en 1956 on est deux ans
plus tard et ils ont eu pendant deux ans
toute l'occasion de faire leur preuve au
pouvoir et évidemment le retour au
pouvoir du général de Gaulle sanctionne
ce qui est un échec pour eux et pour les
contemporains c'est un régime qui a fait
faillite et cette gauche donc communiste
incarne évidemment la faillite du régime
parce qu'elle était aux affaires depuis
les élections du 2 janvier 56 et puis à
gauche il y a quand même des gens qui
sont favorables autour de deux Gaules
Guy Mollet et favorable au retour de De
Gaulle il appelle de Gaulle au pouvoir
le président Coty exhorte le Parlement
de céder la place à de Gaulle et un
gouvernement de salutation nationale de
Gaulle se rend à l'Élysée et pose ses
conditions plein pouvoir puis congés
donner au Parlement enfin constitution
nouvelle à préparer et à soumettre au
référendum
[Musique]
dans le même temps les gaullistes
réunissent leur partisans à l'hôtel de
l'apérouse
le général de Gaulle est investi
le premier mot que je dois dire de
Gaulle est investi très largement avec
337 voix
alors que fimlin le 13 mai est investi
par 250 voix
ce qui montre quand même que il y a une
volonté non pas forcément devoir de
Gaulle revenir aux affaires avec gaieté
de coeur mais l'idée c'est que de Gaulle
seul peut nous sauver de Gaulle et la
solution
[Musique]
le 4 juin 1958 le général de Gaulle
vient à Alger là où pour lui tout avait
commencé trois semaines plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis le balcon du fameux GG le
Gouvernement Général qui avait été
envahi le 13 mai le général cultive
l'ambiguïté
[Applaudissements]
je sais
ce qui s'est passé ici
[Applaudissements]
et je déclare
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
la France considère
que dans toute l'Algérie
il n'y a qu'une seule catégorie
d'habitants
il n'y a que des Français à part entière
les Français à part entière avec les
mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs
la problématique de l'Algérie française
était un problème qu'il considérait dans
son esprit comme devant être résolu en
faveur de l'indépendance cela depuis
longtemps il écrit quelque part que de
toute façon la situation de l'Algérie
devait se dégager de toute solution
d'assujettissement quelle qu'elle fut
simplement tactiquement il aurait dit ça
avant personne ne l'aurait rappelé
quatre mois plus tard le 10 septembre
1958 le général de Gaulle demande aux
Français de ratifier par référendum son
projet de Constitution tout a été mis en
scène pour faire du général l'homme
providentiel celui qui va donner à la
France de nouvelles institutions
c'est égalité que moi-même est mon
gouvernement avant assumer le mandat
exceptionnel
établir un projet de Constitution
nouvelle et de le soumettre à la
décision du peuple de tout mon cœur oh
non la France
je réponds oui
[Musique]
je la République
vive la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le général restera au pouvoir pendant 11
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]